foreign
need some help figuring out how to tell
my mom and brother that I want to move
out of my mom's house I'm 33 years old
and I'm embarrassed at you know I live
with her hope you hear to my voice I got
no shame on this I'm proud of you for
being 33 and saying Now's the Time
[Music]
yo yo what up what up this is John with
the Dr John deloney show the greatest
mental health and marriage and parenting
podcast ever recorded
so glad that you are with us and you are
giving us your most precious resource
time
and
I'm just grateful today I'm grateful
we're into the new year 2023 is off to a
rip-born start I hope it is because
we're recording us before this but
it's off to a great start and I hope you
are haven't already quit on yourself yet
you made some resolutions here's who
we're gonna be here's what I'm gonna
here's some things I'm gonna do to back
up
my new identity
I hope you haven't already given up and
if you have start again today start
again right now start again you can do
this you got it you got it we're all
doing this one this year all right let's
go to uh Trudy in Georgia what's up
Trudy
hey Dr Delaney thanks for taking our
call and our thanks to your wonderful
staff for their help
um we're in a pickle are they wonderful
they are wonderful okay I fully agree
with you I agree with you they're all
looking at me very mean very very mean
they are wonderful all right so true you
are in a pickle which is the most
Georgia thing you could say right now
except for go dogs all right so what's
why are you in a pickle
um I've got a 50 year old brother-in-law
he smokes four or five packs of
cigarette today drinks a lot he's a
hoarder he's got multiple addictions he
doesn't treat my husband well he's a
master manipulator
and he ended up in the hospital and we
got a call at 3am a couple of weeks ago
that they had to put him on a ventilator
and we need you to make these decisions
um we have no clue what he wanted but we
did the very best that we could and
while he was on the event we found out
that he has a 16 year old daughter we
didn't know about his hoarding's out of
control there's a pornography addiction
his heat was cut off he's been telling
damaging lies about my husband and his
friends are calling him a habitual liar
the hospital got him healed up he's off
the vent we had him set up for Rehab but
he refused it and he checked himself out
of the hospital and we've been talking
about this my husband Rob and I and
we're ready to walk away but we know
that another call is going to come in
the middle of the night and so we had a
couple of questions for you and wondered
if you could help us know how do we
handle the next call that comes for the
next if Ken should we try to meet our
niece and then for me the guilt just
bites I was raised to take care of
family but enough is enough my
father-in-law called me two weeks before
he died both of my in-laws have passed
away and he called me two weeks before
he died and he asked me to take care of
the brother-in-law and it's just a hot
stinking mess and we were if any words
of wisdom you could share with us we'd
really appreciate it yeah I've got a lot
of opinions on this one hey let me uh
let me bring Rob in and
um I want to hear what he has to say
first I mean as well in addition to what
you just brought to us but um yeah I've
got some as you can imagine I've got an
opinion uh hang on one second
hey Rob
hey Dr Maloney thank you for taking her
call you got it man what's up Chuck all
right so your your uh Trudy says you've
got you're all in it all right
yeah yeah we're in a
what's your sign and a hard place it's
been hard for a very long time so this
is most of my life so
well can I tell you this before you say
anything uh from what Trudy said it
sounds to me like this has been hard for
a long long time
and is a very simple
yet very difficult path forward
maybe super super difficult all right so
tell me what tell me what you're working
through my parents were very much
enablers of this they just kind of
looked past it oh that's how he is and
okay and I swear if I hear anybody else
say that I might hit them but
um you know it just
this behavior is going on so long and
been allowed so long
man I just why why Rob let me ask you
why are you involved at all
your brother well yeah hold on hold on
your brother and your parents
buy their behavior told you
here's what we think of you
and you have continued to say yeah but
okay I'll figure out a way to make make
the relationship better I'll figure a
way to fix this
and not one time did brother or mom or
dad ever ask you to fix it they told you
here's the way we're choosing to live
our life
and for some reason you have tried
to stay connected to this madness why
yeah I don't The Only Thing Once me and
Judy were established as a couple uh was
we had kids and we wanted them to know
their grandparents their grandparents
were bad people okay that's fair and I
don't and just because
um they didn't have good boundaries or
they enabled I don't think their parents
are bad people but you can not be a bad
person you can be a fine person but I
can't spend time with you
you know what I mean some of my closest
friends I would say some of my closest
friends and friends I've had for all of
my life I don't want him to spend a ton
of time with my kids if any right I love
them but I've got some pretty
significant boundaries with them too
um okay so bring me forward your
brother's real real sick you stepped in
had to make some out of the blue hard
calls in the middle of the night
probably some life or death calls
um you guys set up some plan you thought
okay this is gonna scare him straight
and he just walked right back into the
who he was and how he was oh and by the
way you have a niece that you didn't
know about yeah yeah we we didn't even
find that out from him we found that out
through uh
trying to track down his insurance and a
man asked me he said well can you name
his dependent I'm like well he shouldn't
have one uh he's like well we have a 16
year old girl listed okay and that's how
I found out I had a niece and my parents
had a granddaughter they never knew
anything about
um
which which the way you're saying that
and the way Trudy wait truly the way you
explain that y'all sounded surprised yet
nothing in this in your brother's
Behavior pattern would suggest this is a
surprise
uh yeah yeah I would I would say yeah I
don't get really surprised anymore it's
just
you know you these things come out of
nowhere of course that's right that's
right you know but I'm not surprised any
lied about it yeah it's not a surprise
so how can I help you yeah true true to
you there
I'm here yep so uh what what's what
comes next for y'all how can I help you
with what comes next
so we handled the call that comes at 3am
for the next of Ken
the next call that comes
uh what do you mean
to the hot say the hospital calls us and
says hey your brother's here we had to
put him on a ventilator we need you to
make decisions you're his next of kin
okay do we we just go ahead and do the
same thing we just went through again
and try to make the very best decisions
we can
do we refer him back to the state
we don't we don't know what to do I
think that go ahead Rob
yeah part of that Dr John is he has
nothing in place he doesn't have a
uh what we used to call a living will he
doesn't have a will
he doesn't have nobody knows
how to assist him in
paying his bills anything we you know
none of that stuff uh I I don't have
anything in place
and that tells me
either he's very very sick and you need
to get with an attorney
a very psychologically sick you get with
an attorney and have his civil rights
taken away and take take
um over custody of him essentially
or
if he is of sound mind
and he's just choosing to be the way he
is
then you have to hear his behavior as a
language and he is telling you I don't
want anything to do with you I never
have and I never will
and you and Trudy have to make your just
your choices Now set up your boundaries
now
and if you get a call in the middle of
the night and you say no regardless he's
my brother come come with me I'm gonna
be there for him
um
then you all make that choice and when
the Call Comes at 3am then you help make
the decisions that you got to make at
3am
or you say I'm drawing a line
and I'm gonna tell him
either you get a living will or when I
get a call at 3am I'm gonna tell them
that we are estranged and I will I
refuse to make decisions for him I refer
him back to the state
oh yeah that's kind of that's kind of
where we were I can't tell you which one
of those to do but that's what we were
thinking too I I can't tell you what to
do what I can tell you is you need to
have that conversation and you and Trudy
Shake on it and you make it Ironclad
before you get that call
because when you get that call you're
gonna be really emotional it's gonna be
you know whatever whatever the
temperature happens to be outside and
suddenly you're going to find yourself
two weeks and ten thousand dollars
down a road that you don't want to be
down
yeah yeah
right and so uh
I I would not be able to sleep at night
it's just me
if I didn't come up with really firm
boundaries and I go make a direct have a
direct conversation with my brother I do
not care ones one second
what quote unquote other people are
saying about me
or what he's telling other people about
me could care less
I could care less what other people like
just saying he's a liar
they have no bearing on my life zero
none
I want to be able to look my brother in
the eye and say if you will have a will
I will help make decisions not if but
when the next call comes if you won't
make a will
and designate me as X Y and Z you will
be a ward of the state you get to choose
and I would want to have look him in I
don't need none of that uh I'm just
telling you
ah you see what I'm saying yeah yeah and
then when the Call Comes
you could you'll be able to weep and be
sad that your brother's passing away or
your brother's very very sick or
whatever but you'll also be able to know
I looked my brother in the eye and said
I will help if you will help and he said
no
either forcefully or through his
behavior he answered my question he said
no I don't want your help
yeah
you know what I mean yeah the problem
with having that conversation is not
what I've been through so many times I'm
so mad I don't even know if I can
have a five minute conversation you've
got civil conversations that's that's
that's that's up to you
um
I think you can I think you you can
decide to or decide not to
but I'm not I I'm I'm simply telling you
what I what I would do I can't I can't
put myself in your shoes right now
you've been dealing with this your whole
life
yeah yeah
um and uh so and as it refers to his his
new niece any conversations like it
would be inappropriate to just bombard a
16 year old with hey we're your family
um
that's that's what we've been discussing
today it's got to go through her whoever
her parent or Guardian is right now yeah
yeah
and yeah yeah that's what I told Trudy
is that I do not want to turn this
girl's world upside down uh it sounds
like it already is upside down
um well I don't even know if she has
contact with him we still have it
okay reach that uh well actually I I
would I would communicate directly with
um
if you choose good on that road I would
identify her parent or Guardian
and communicate with them and let them
know hey we are
so and so's sane brother and
sister-in-law
and we found out we had a niece we
understand that our my brother my
brother-in-law is not a person of
character is a has a whole bunch of
challenges going on
um
we have our stuff together
and we now have identified her your
daughter as a new family member if and
when you are ready or she is ready and
wants to reach out fantastic if not we
fully understand right now
and that parent or Guardian may say we
don't want nothing to do with y'all get
out of our Lives we've had enough of
your family through your brother and
she's a minor so great and when she
turns 18
or she turns 21 and you want to reach
back out great now she's an adult and
she can make adult decisions
but right now don't bombard a child
with
you know contact saying oh by the way
that's that's a child can't carry that
weight that's why they got adults in
their lives so they got parents so work
through the parent or Guardian on that
one
um and so like I said earlier Rob and
Trudy this is it's it's heavy
and it's got a lot of weight to it
but the solution is very very simple
for a long long time your brother has
said I don't want you in my life
and yet you've said nope you're my
brother I'm gonna be here
and then when the call came in the
middle of the night you showed up
you're you're a family of outstanding
character and you go above and beyond
and then you go above and beyond that
and Trudy you can't help be held liable
for the dying wish of a dad who never
established boundaries never established
accountability never established
character or discipline in his son
you take care of him for me do you do
the job I never did
he doesn't get to lob that Grenade on
you as he passes away
it's not for you to carry
it's just not
you can love him you can love him
and that might look like
um power of attorney that might look
like you become his legal guardian
because he has lost his mind that might
be that you say we will support you uh
we'll we'll make those calls in the
middle of the night but only after you
do your part which is get a will get a
medical power of attorney get a fill in
the blank all the paperwork done
the path is pretty simple
Rob Trudy I'll go have a date together
cry together
be frustrated and angry together and
then walk away with a plan on here's how
we're gonna handle what comes next and
stick to the plan they all make together
I'm so sorry y'all are in this moment
but I'm glad you'll have each other to
lean on and decide what to do next let
me know y'all decide and I'll pass it
along to our listeners we'll be right
back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com
deloni and get the home buyer Edge today
this is a paid advertisement in MLS ID
1591 in MLS consumeraccess.org equal
housinglender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite
100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and not
available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to
Jennifer and welcome to Miami what's up
Jennifer
hey what's up what's up partying what
are you up to
oh you know still in this chilly weather
just a little bit just a little bit is
it chilly in Miami
I mean it's like 75.
the salt trucks are out driving around
no don't touch it it's like that's like
a balmy August day in the north all
right so what's going on
okay so I have the most wonderful
question for you I've been really
dealing with this um the past few years
how do I discuss
marital abuse
um with my children without putting
something on them without being you know
disrespectful to their father
um but also being authentic I mean they
were there you know they know uh to an
extent
um that things were different than maybe
some of their their friends uh home life
but I'm just I've really been at a loss
lately
how old are your kids
uh they range in age from 10 to 25. okay
um the self-contact with their dad
yes
they do yes now they do okay
um
what kind of abuse was it
um
I
was married for over two decades and I
ended up
working for three years
um it started off as kind of like a
emergency safety plan kind of thing when
I was still terrified to try to leave
again and then it ended up being more of
an escape plan with the local police
department and two different therapists
um obviously my children didn't know
that but um it was
pretty much everything
um and then add a little evil on top of
that I was thinking the other day if
there was an Aces score for being
married mine would be like a 13. if that
would be a problem so you know not to be
dramatic or anything no no no but
um
so you got beat up a lot
um not initially
um but as the years progressed yes it
started
um the physical actually really started
when I was pregnant with my youngest and
um you know I have truly been crying out
to God in the middle of being told I was
going to be murdered okay
um
there was psychological abuse on top of
the physical abuse
yes and it has made it very challenging
um especially with my my older children
because
my character assassination started when
they were very very small
um you know things like who Do You Love
More mom or dad or if Mom and Dad ever
got a divorce
uh you're gonna go with Daddy right and
this is at a time when I didn't know at
the time that he was being unfaithful to
me again but
um and I had never ever divorce had
never even been uttered
um where anything to do with my side of
the family was always very very bashed
and obviously isolated um it got to a
point not gotcha point it started um but
I had no frame of reference for a
healthy relationship
you know it was just very very isolating
but he's such a beautiful Charming
successful
intelligent giving man and so when he
started even realizing towards the end
like she's I was starting you know I was
learning some boundaries in how to
distance in a way
um he had started really going out of
his way to
um
say things about me in our very small
local community
um that would make anything that I said
maybe not believed or distrusted and
with our children he would always say
you're such a liar you're such a liar
just for everything and um it was very
interesting to you know I was told at
the end a lot of gaslighting you know
um that
my unforgiveness of the past was what
was holding back our relationship that I
really was he thought I had mental
issues and if I ever left him that he
would insist on the psychological
evaluation that maybe I needed to be on
medication
it was a lot of not just
um severe physical but
um all the things that have made it very
confusing for my especially my older
children where they looked at me and
said I just don't know what to believe
and I had never tried to defend myself
because I didn't want to bring them in
the middle but I realized that he was
saying things
um and it you know really put a strain
on a relationship sure because I wasn't
saying anything and the other side was
saying a lot and 99 of it was a lie so
at 25 your 25 year old
either is showing the same
Psychopathology as their dad or is
beginning to put two and two together
she actually has she's my only daughter
she has quite severe intellectual
disabilities and
um she reads through it all from the
beginning and it has taken a lot for her
to now even have
um relationship in a way he's been sober
for a little over a year and that's the
longest that I have seen
which I know sounds awful but in a lot
of ways it's so much scarier
um because he can be more conniving and
I I know this sounds better and I don't
mean it that way let me stop for a
second
uh how long have you all been divorced
it has been over three years
I can feel the terror that still pulses
through your veins
listen listen you're unable to literally
unable to answer a yes or no question
because
your brain starts churning so fast for
the 40 different ways I can use what you
just said against you and you got to
come up with another reason another
solution and a way to diffuse it in a
way to move it and push it let's push it
left it's okay but we're gonna do this
and you have to move like that
because your body recognizes one alarm
system and it's Terror
right you're like oh correct 100 okay
I've become a politician how do I answer
this without getting into trouble
and listen that is the part that
um
like so to answer your question like
very very directly with adult children I
will answer questions honestly when they
ask
or if they're about to do something that
I think is going to get them hurt
okay
um
I will not go throwing grenades and I
will also preface it with this one
important thing kids know they are equal
part mom and dad and so when they find
out something evil about one of the
parents then they cannot help it but
internalize that so for therefore so am
I
right and so all of those conversations
have to be prefaced with
um I will tell you about what happened
when or dad says you whatever or even if
you Circle back to your 21 year old and
said hey a year ago you said that Dad
told you that I was crazy and I had
mental health issues and all this
there's way more to this story and one
day when if you ever want to know I will
be I promise to be honest with you even
when it's hard
okay and leave it there
your 25 year old who struggles with
intellectual disabilities sometimes not
always folks who struggle with
intellectual disabilities become savants
at reading social cues oh my gosh you
yes you nailed it and so she may
struggle with reading she may struggle
with arithmetic but God knows she knows
relationships because that's the way her
brain has had to evolve to survive
yeah she might not be able to put her
finger on it but she knows that guy's
not like I'm his body energy is telling
me something different than the words
coming out of his mouth and it's
disoriented right yes and he used does a
great job telling her that she's dumb or
that she's stupid or creating some world
where she can only exist with him
Fair
or doesn't exist at all correct you
won't even acknowledge
there you go so here's because she
doesn't she doesn't play into that's
right uh doesn't play his rules doesn't
play his game yes you still do
yes you're still participating yes and
it the greatest gift you can give your
children at this point is not a story or
a narrative that will come down the road
the greatest gift you can give your kids
is to begin healing
yes
and you haven't done that yet
I feel like I've come a really really
and I'm thankful I know I'm I'm not I'm
not you know even close to being there
but I'm so grateful I've done a lot of
hard work I think what has this has come
up is my oldest son
um has expressed some like hurt and
frustration with me because I was dad's
biggest cheerleader and he and and he's
because he has experienced
um The Mask slip when there wasn't
sobriety all the time and so for a very
short time just the way you said that's
so great when there wasn't sobriety all
the time when my husband was an abusive
violent drunk
well even after I divorced him I know I
know it was so yeah here's what will
happen in this please please please
please please please please please hear
the the loving spirit with which I'm
about to say this okay
please please please because I'm walking
a dangerously thin razor and I probably
wouldn't bring this up if you and I were
in counseling and Therapeutics together
for a couple of sessions because this is
too soon but I've only got you for a few
minutes okay oh no go ahead I love it um
your child is right to ask you
why didn't you protect us
yes they're they are right to ask that
question and
as a terrified frightened
powerless person in a highly abusive
relationship
there's not an answer for that question
right yes yes that's what I have grieved
that is the conversation that I have had
at times or whether it was writing a
letter
um a couple times in person specifically
with my older children
possibly possibly possibly writing the
letter and and but reading it I know I I
have done both okay I have apologized to
them
for not protecting them and I think they
need to hear you apologize to you
yeah because the way you are
communicating now you still don't
believe that you have needs or value
I can hear it in you even this call is
how can I fix their life
not recognizing it the greatest gift you
can give them is you anchoring into
something firm anchoring into something
into bedrock
ex can you explain
when you are
in a committed highly abusive
relationship you're a kite in the wind
yes that is occasionally pulled down to
be set on fire or stomped on and then
sent back up into the air
and when you sever that relationship the
reason that relationship is so hard to
sever is you know that that's going to
cut that kite string and then you are
tossed to the wind and if you look at
the data women who leave abusive men
they're they're they fall into poverty
with higher rates they everything in
their life goes down and weirdly not
weirdly frustratingly it often Works
inversely for men the abusive guidance
up better off financially ends up with a
better fill in the blank right right and
so you hang on because I don't know
where I end up if I cut this line
and you summoned The Bravery and the
courage and the strength
that millions of abused women before you
have summoned and you cut that line
and all of a sudden you realized you
were on the ground the whole time
and it I agree and I also uh think that
one of the biggest
things that I didn't know that I had to
learn was I mean I knew it in inside of
me instinctively
um leaving you know people would be like
why if someone got to win why didn't why
don't you leave why don't you I mean he
cheats he does say all the things and
and it's because when you make that
decision or you even start to pull away
it's actually more dangerous for you for
such a time you know it's you appeasing
seems like a safer place for such a long
time until it isn't anymore because you
can't appease that's right that's right
you know so it's a really a big deal and
I recently uh lost one of my sons he was
killed just a few months ago and uh so I
I had a lot of this resurface a lot that
I really thought I had worked through
because I've done a lot of hard work
um well Jennifer Jennifer Jennifer you
lost a son
yes how old
he was almost 21 he was killed he didn't
pass right away he passed about a week
and a half after what happened
he there's a lot more to it than this
but essentially
um he was crossing the street after some
other things had happened his car was no
longer functioning to drive and
um three or four men in a car hit him on
the street and left him for dead
oh my gosh I'm so sorry have you had to
grieve this all by yourself
um no I've had a wonderful wonderful
gracious support system of
um some family and close friends that
have really stepped up it's been amazing
humans are awesome I've really been
grateful but
um I think with that all the things that
I hadn't done in a really long time like
wake up in the middle of the night from
bad dreams
um about my ex-husband uh or even just
feeling I think that as the numbness is
wearing off because like you have to be
numb for so long to survive and as you
you dethaw
I'm realizing how angry I am yes
and you're a lot you're allowed to be
angry
and you've never been allowed to be
angry before
correct but I don't want it to be
put on my children if you don't let them
know that you are angry
they will feel it on you and they will
blame themselves
or
they will in a perverse sideways way
try to do some reverse algorithm math
and be like well maybe Dad was right
yeah you have to tell them how
devastated you are
yeah how
just raged out angry you are
you have to
and you have to allow your body to
experience this
is grief
and you've had people walking alongside
you and bringing you casseroles and
showing up with you and take care of
your lawn and they've been really really
remarkable
yeah
but you got to be yeah my kids have
commented that
that hasn't happened for their father of
course and I don't know how to answer
that
he has chosen not to surround himself
with people who love him there we go
that's his choice
I'm sad for him but that's the choice
that he made yeah as often as you can
make a moving forward conversations
about you
okay what you felt I didn't feel safe
why didn't you feel safe to your 15 year
old
it's adult conversations it was just a
scary time I was younger and I didn't
fully understand my own strength and I
didn't fully understand what being
married was like
I'll talk to you more about when you're
older to your 25 year old I was scared
because your dad told me he would murder
me
yeah
right you see the difference there
and I'm gonna say some hard things about
your father I need you to look at me and
believe me when I say I do not see any
of this in you
yeah
you're an amazing young son young
daughter young whoever
um was the one who chose to stay
um with Dad full-time and he
would comment to me at times but Mom if
I leave he literally stepped into my
shoes the you know where walking in and
it you know Dad's threatening to kill
himself and all those things because he
realized as
people were detaching after so much time
like oh gosh I need to reel them back in
or that's what I'm assuming and um you
know that's been such the struggle is
that it's con I want to run in there and
grab my child and say
you can't have him not because I don't
want him to have relationship with his
father but because it's been so
devastating to watch my child
choose for or even be manipulated to
choose to stay when it's hurting him and
he even has said to me at times mom I've
I've wished at times that Dad was dead
not because I want him to die or hurt
but then he would be at peace and we
would be at peace and yet he still
chooses his father in so many ways I
feel so hurt like yeah you know somebody
how old is he how old is he
he's 22.
saying something like your daddy's not
well
yeah oh for sure and I'm I it's it's
unbelievable to me the young man you are
that you love hurting people so well
absolutely and anytime you want to come
home
my door is always open for you
it's just saying it again and saying it
again and saying it again okay and what
I'll tell you is if something is not
safe
you talked about it earlier you they
start making plans and you start like
okay it's not safe here so we're gonna
have a like a strategy for calling the
cops for doing this for doing this for
doing this
if something isn't safe that's the Bell
that is the alarm system you got to get
out of that situation
your 22 year old son cannot be
responsible for an adult father who
keeps threatening to kill himself
he's not trained for that he doesn't
have for the professional skills for
that he's too enmeshed in that
relationship he can't do it
and so I'm gonna call 9-1-1 every single
time I'ma tell my son son neither you or
I are trained for this so we're just
gonna start calling 911 every single
time every single time we're calling
because we can't handle it and if Dad
says if you call anyone again I'm gonna
well Dad now I'm really gonna call him
because I don't I don't have any other
play I don't know I don't know how I can
help you
there's so oh man there's so much here
Jennifer
um
so much here
um
I think the safest not safest the
smartest play right now for you is to
spend some time grieving your son
I want you to write your son a letter
and tell them how much you miss him
and actually I want you to call
um an evening together with all your
kids here as as the holidays are
approaching and I know this call is
going to be aired after New Year's but
um it's right before Christmas when
we're when we're on this call I want you
to invite your kids over for an evening
and I want you all to write your son
their brother who passed away a letter
let them know how much they miss him
I don't know how heartbroken they are
and I want y'all to share that grief
together as a family
and if you need to have one or two
friends over because your family isn't
doesn't have the practice of shared
grief that's great if you have a
counselor you want to bring over great
but I think y'all should all write a
letter and read them together
and just notice that empty seat there at
the table we miss brother
and then as questions come up
with your adult kids
again let them know I don't see this in
you
but
um I was young and I was scared and I
didn't know where to turn next and
I'm sorry that you went through that and
I'm also sorry that I experienced that
and here we are
what we can control is what comes next
and what nobody can ever take away is
how much I love you to the Moon and back
and the moon and back and the Moon and
back
it's a mess it's a mess it's a mess and
your kids are lucky to have you Jennifer
[Music]
call anytime anytime
and um I'll walk alongside you thank you
for being brave we'll be right back
bologna here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor better help let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist at under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back hey before we take
this uh next call
um just want to take a moment
to shout out
um just got word this morning that the
great Mike Leach passed away and the
football coach uh when I was at Texas
Tech uh he was the football coach that
re-imagined football and this is uh was
a character was always saying things
that were just wild and he was super fun
in interviews and was just a just a
character brought Joy
um to to lots and lots of folks and so
Jess shout out to his family and to his
wife and his kids and that Community as
They Mourn the passing of a legend and
here's here's the thing I always
remember about Coach Leach
um
he went to law school out there at
Pepperdine and I don't know how much
this is folklore at this point but
he never played a down a football in his
life but he loved it he was obsessed
with it and he used to draw plays while
he was in law school and wonder why
don't people just run it like this like
if they just did it like this then
they could get around this and this and
this and this
and so he
on the margins of his law school
notebooks
reimagined football and the Air Raid
Offense that we see all over the NFL now
on college football was largely out of
that guy's head and
um
it's a pretty amazing amazing fun guy
it's so interesting so he did this thing
where at the end of every football
season to kind of reset his mind he
would find a thing that he would go down
a rabbit hole on just learn everything
about it and one year he picked Pirates
and he got real obsessed with pirates
and if you know anything about Mike
Leach he he has followed this pirate
Legacy and it's just become part of his
thing now
but just a few weeks ago I told my wife
what I wanted for Christmas was some
books some ancient books on dragons
I decided I want to be like coach Leach
and at the end of like every year I just
want to learn a whole bunch about a
thing and this year I want to learn
about dragons I don't know about Eastern
dragons and Western dragons and or the
mythology of dragons where they come
from and
my wife's like that's fantastic and so
I'm hoping to unwrap because Christmas
is in a couple of days to some books on
on dragons but I got the idea from coach
and so coach we're gonna miss you and to
his family
um we are grateful that I know the
family of a coach is a family that sees
their their dad or husband only in
passing and um thank you for sharing
with us for all these years all right
let's go to uh Sam in Orlando Florida
what's up Sam
uh how you doing doctor I'm good my
brother what's up
I need some help figuring out how to
tell my mom and brother that I want to
move out of my mom's house okay uh I'm
33 years old
um
I'm actually kind of I'm embarrassed
that you know I live with her okay
um and I've just really been
I think I'm ready
I feel like I need to take take the
plunge okay
um
straight through all the way since you
were kid
[Music]
I've lived with her since I graduated
from college that was 2011. okay how
come you how come you stayed
well I really didn't have a like I had a
hard time like finding work and I
couldn't afford to you know to live on
my own
um you know so just kind of
you know did what I could you know you
know to get by
um you know recently I did a career
change uh you know I started working in
the uh I.T help desk you know then went
into I.T so hopefully to make a little
bit more money cool
um
yeah so can I ask you let me ask you
this brother
um and by the way I hope you hear it in
my voice there's I got no shame on this
okay
I'm proud of you for being 33 and saying
Now's the Time okay and we could go
replay like what are you doing and where
are you babe why I'm not gonna do that
man I think the the best use of our
energy right now is what comes next
right moving forward
just listening to your voice for a few
seconds and just listen to you tell your
story about yourself
you don't think very highly of my new
friend Sam why not
why do you think Sam is is kind of a
loser
pretty much hit the you pretty much hit
the nail on the head
um where does that come from did your
mom talk to you like that no uh
absolutely not your brother
no neither one of them where does it
come from man
I guess it comes you know from myself I
guess I maybe I put pressure on myself
um you know I you know I've
you know
I've watched
um like uh like the Dave Ramsey shows uh
here and there like you know it helped
me uh get out of you know get out of
debt and help me with my career change
okay but I like from what I understand
it just seems like like if you're at my
age and you live with your parents
regardless of the reason like you're a
loser no that's nonsense that's not true
that is a part of that story that you've
you've kind of morphed and taken in a
really dark rat to tell yourself
okay I do think
uh I mean there's there's plenty of
people who live with their parents who
are helping out because their parents
are old age they've got health issues
um that move home for a season to like
pay their house off or to get out of
debt and figure out what comes next or
they lose their job life happens life
happens
I would ask you as just your buddy dude
if you and I were just hanging out at a
bar having a beer I would ask you
hey it was hard to find work in 2011.
and fast forward it's 12 years later and
you're still telling yourself those same
stories
I can't find a job I'm not worth finding
a job I can't afford to live I just kind
of am and over the last 12 years you
have naturally
taking the easy path the hard path is
dude in six months I am moving out of
this apart this house I'm getting my own
apartment and so I have to have this
much dollars which means I have to take
a second and third job or I Gotta Throw
my shoulders back a little bit
and commit to doing a bang-up job at
work and they're going to recognize me
and then in nine months they're going to
move me to this position I'm gonna move
to that position see what I'm saying so
something has held you back there and
um I'm glad to hear it's not your your
mom wouldn't tell calling you her loser
son and it wasn't your brother being
like Oh loser still like no man if
you've been helping out and taking care
of somebody who wasn't well or whatever
good for you good for you what has
brought you to this moment that like
this time I'm 33 it's time
uh well I wrote down uh some reasons to
leave and concerns that I have okay
um if that helps yeah so so the reasons
I want to leave
um I just think as Dave Ramsey put it
you know you never learn how to fly like
unless you read The Nest that's very
very true you there is a maturity
there is a growth and development
immaturity
um that you have not undergone because
you haven't had to there's something
about saying if I don't
earn this money I don't have a place to
live like there's some that builds
strength right if I don't push this bar
off my chest it will collapse my my ribs
right like there's some that's how you
grow strength right is adding weight on
the bar and he is exactly one thousand
percent right
yes sir
uh I'm the only one in my Social Circle
that I know of who lives with who lives
with my mom correct uh
and
you know I was like my mom won't be
around forever I need to figure out like
how I'm going to sustain myself when she
leaves this world okay and also like I
feel guilty but it's like every other
weekend
uh more or less like she goes over to my
brothers and hangs out with her
grandkids
um I enjoy having a house you know to
myself you know you know she's like
retired
um you know she's a homebody and you
know we're around each other a lot and
Sam get your own place brother get your
own place
okay get your own place
you should feel nervous
you should feel angsty about it
you should do it with
um not uh do get a place you can afford
you're going to feel a little bit lonely
it's going to feel weird
and then have some of your buddies in
your Social Circle over on a regular
basis have Monday night whatever is at
your house
poker Nights video game nights dungeons
I don't know whatever nerd things people
what you're into I don't know
um like for me it would be like come
over and watch the fights or come over
and I don't know what things you're into
but
create a world where
your place becomes a place where people
hang out and it will develop very very
quickly
but it is time but I don't want you to
go because you're a loser now
like I'm the only guy I don't want that
to be the reason you go because Dave
Ramsey said I'm a loser if I don't want
that to be the reason you go even if
they're right
I want you to go because it's time for
the next chapter of your life
it's time for you to build the your the
next uh
to not build I want you to plant the the
roots that will become the next branch
of your family tree
mm-hmm
do you ever want to get married have
kids do that whole thing
yeah
yeah I'm not gonna lie man I don't see
myself having a wife and kids I mean not
not because of my current situation like
I see
I mean I see people with a wife and kids
and uh maybe it's my loner state of mind
but I don't see myself
uh you know being a husband and a dad
I won't take that from you what I will
tell you is
um
foreign
romantic relationships a shot
is is robbing yourself of the deepest
and greatest Joys life has to offer
understood okay I can't put that on you
man if you want to not get married and
you want to live best or life your whole
life and not have kids cool
um in the same way you won't fully
understand the weight of maturity the
weight of growing up the way of being
adult until you got your own place
there's a deeper layer you won't truly
understand what love is what life is
about you won't truly understand what
you are capable of until you hold your
first kid
and you won't fully understand just how
terrifying and scary this place is
all of it right
and by the way if you're around a bunch
of people that are negative about their
wife and kids those kids those people
suck get new friends all right get new
people to hang out with
yes sir here's a here's a funny story I
think I've told it on the show before
but my friend my friend John
um we hung out every Monday night for
years and years and years me and him and
Todd and we hung out for years and years
and years and years and years
and then he had a kid and his wife is
awesome her name's Jen just absolutely
adores from my favorite people on the
planet but after like a year John
wouldn't hang out with us after he had
this new kid
and
I'm not gonna lie I was like man
Jennifer is the worst
she is not who like man I thought she
was super cool but he's got to stay home
all the time
and it wasn't until I had my son
that I realized I don't want to hang out
with those idiots I want to sit here on
my couch and hold my child or I want to
lay down on the floor and just stare
into his eyes
and he can't even focus on me yet and I
asked John about that and he smiled and
he's like yeah no offense but I I would
rather be with my wife and kids and come
to find out Jennifer was like dude go be
with your friends get out of the house
and he was like no man I want to be with
you and the baby and I asked him why
didn't you ever tell me and he said man
I couldn't have explained that
I couldn't have explained that kind of
love I felt that's just something you
gotta experience so I tell you that to
tell you
um there is an intellectual side to it
but also man there is a part of your
heart and soul that will open up that
you will never understand
But to answer your question it's like
your original original question it
sounds like
you getting a friend that you trust
maybe your brother maybe even your mom
and you say it's time for me to move out
33 I'm gonna be 34 it's 20 23 is right
around the corner it's time for me to
move out here's my plan in three months
and five months whatever I'm gonna have
my own place and I'm gonna do Sunday
lunches I'd love you all come over for
Sunday lunch
or whatever the thing is or once a month
I want to whatever your mom may go oh
thank God get out of my house or she
might be devastated right who knows yeah
that's that good that's one of my that's
that's like my concerns you know because
you know I'm not one of those guys who
just lives with her and doesn't
contribute you know I pay her rent yeah
no dude I'm not thinking that at all
yeah and like the only thing she says
that she does for me is put a roof over
my head and I just got done asking her
um hey does the monies I pay you really
hope and she says yes you don't know how
much yeah so it's like like I mean she
I mean we should be able to get by like
without me and so here's here's one of
the poisons of the way your mind works
okay Sam
is you think about a thing
and you do not seek out true data
you think about a thing and become
Paralyzed by the thoughts of that thing
and then you start trying to figure out
well if I do this then if I do that then
if I do that but then if I do that then
that's gonna happen then this is gonna
happen
and it's a deep deep seated pattern of
rumination that leads to paralysis
analysis paralysis and but you have it
times 10.
so the way through this is sitting down
with your mom saying mom it is time for
me to move out you mentioned the other
day
that um the money that I pay for rent is
really important to you I don't want to
leave you an alert because I've been
here a decade now
right uh and it's by the way it's easy
to be like oh dude what a loser move out
on your own get your own play well now
you've established a life for your mom
too right so now you're you're into this
thing and so you have to leave
gracefully
um and so get firm data from your mom
mom can you survive
if I move out and establish my own name
my own place my own life and maybe one
day in my own family
um be very specific about the finances
okay dollar amounts not yeah I'll be
fine I want to see it where does your
income come from how would you pay these
bills how would you feel right see what
I'm saying and it may be that she moves
in with you
she becomes a guest in your house do
what if that's the case then why I mean
I may as well stay with her then you
figure out a way to buy the house
because right now you're paying rent for
somebody else's home that you're gonna
have to split with your brother someday
didn't say cool I will purchase this
home
and I will figure out my employment
situation I will save up I will do this
the right way
um not to further endanger myself
financially but I'm gonna buy this house
and he will be you will live in my home
and just flip it on its script and that
would be a conversation with your
brother too
right or your brother can help
contribute as well say brother I've
given up all of my 20s and now I'm into
my 30s taking care of Mom living here
and I have it has been a great Advantage
for me but I'm also paying all of the
expenses and I'm ready to move out but
Mom can't afford to live by herself so
either she's got to move in with one of
us or we have to contribute to her
staying in this house what are you gonna
contribute
I hear you is it fair yes sir
are you gonna do any of this stuff
as soon as I get off this call I'm gonna
you know have this conversation with her
and ask her and just just you know talk
to her okay I would start that
conversation by
few sons are as blessed as I have been
to had a mom who let me stay this long
and this is conversation one of a couple
of conversations but I want you to know
that it's time for me to find my own
place and I want to be very gracious in
how I do that but it's time
and I would write down like on a note
card or a piece of notebook paper very
specific we need to talk about finances
I won't leave you in a Lurch uh we need
to figure out what comes next you have
where do you get money is she on Social
Security does she have a pension who
knows where she's getting money but be
very specific about that stuff
um and then prepare for this to be
either a she cheers and goes finally
Sam's growing up get out or she's
devastated oh my Sam you can't leave
whatever
um and then be prepared to say okay cool
let's we're gonna let's I want us to
think on this it's doing this I don't
even know what the apartments cost
around here I don't know what homes cost
um let's Circle back in Friday we'll
have second part of this conversation
and I'll bring brother too right and
we're gonna do this systematically and
the next three to six to nine months
whatever your financial situation is
let's plan to jump
let's plan to jump
unless it's gonna leave Mom destitute
and then you and brother sit down and
figure out together what your next steps
are
um
not gonna beat you up man
but your gut is right sounds like it's
time so let's make a good solid plan
I'm gonna stop analyzing everything
let's move to action we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back hey I was
wondering okay so you don't know this
but if when Kelly's on the show she's
got her hair done it's done all nice but
when she's just like editing things or
working uh she usually has it up in a
ponytail and she has this big giant
barcode tattooed on the back of her neck
I don't know where she got that but
right underneath it it says I love Kelly
Clarkson and I never understood that and
now I forgot since I've been gone I have
an Elvis tattoo on my neck where's all
this going that's that's well you make
up over it so hard that one's more like
on your throat
you guys can't see it she has so much
powder and so much cover up on her neck
right now like I'm surprised that your
head doesn't lean over but see it just
just like that just lean over a bit but
right beneath the barcode
um huge Kelly Clarkson fan it's
incredible
um
and I guess this is is this your
favorite song
not necessarily I just thought it was a
fitting song Give it our second call
what's your favorite Kelly Clarkson song
I don't know that I have one oh you just
love them all I love them all equally
I love them all the same
I'm gonna be situ Bingo I'm gonna be
saying that all day I don't have a
favorite one I love them all John all
right songs called Because of You by
Kelly Clarkson
ah Connie Clarkson what's that uh
fantastic
song's called because of you and it goes
like this
I will not make the same mistakes that
you did I will not let myself cause my
heart so much misery I will not break
the way you did you fell so hard I've
learned the hard way to never let it get
that far
because of you I never stray too far
from the sidewalk because of you I
learned to play on the safe side so I
don't get hurt because of you I find it
hard to trust not only me but everyone
around me because of you I'm afraid
I lose my way and it's not too long
before you point out I cannot cry
because I know that's weakness in your
eyes I'm forced to fake a smile a laugh
every day of my life my heart can't
possibly break
when it wasn't even whole to start with
that is a good song I Like It Well Done
Kelly I might get a Kelly Clarkson
tattoo as well America go get Kelly
Clarkson tattoos we'll see you soon